[Music]
this could end up being one of the best
things we've ever seen on YouTube
or one of the worst let's go [__]
let's go
I have felt the lowest I've ever felt in
my life
during this experience and overcoming
that that is what that is where I'm
getting my confidence wrong that is
where because I have proven to myself on
a daily basis what about I'm not trying
[__] because I'll prove it if one of
these lads gets knocked out in front of
the entire [__] world and they could
up the level of DOMA every time you
cheerio
every video every social media post you
ever put out the full stop on the end of
your last sentence is gonna be a gift if
you lie in their sleep on the [__]
floor and I don't want that for my boss
usually YouTube has made videos bitching
about each other it'll get in the ring
it's certainly like man
until now
[Music]
imagine 8,000 people seeing your head
absolutely crushed
[Applause]
[Music]
I've already primed the speech never
will yeah I wouldn't know I wonder
with you
I'm not gonna take compliments from his
weaknesses
I will take confidence from my straight
[Music]
[Applause]